[Zene]
üdvözlök mindenkit a navigátor
podcastben a mai vendégem nagy lajos a
hámnak az alapítója köszönjük szépen
lajos hogy elfogadtad a meghívásunkat
szia köszönöm a meghívást lajosról
röviden annyit mondanék el hogy 33 éves
két gyereknek az édesapja és egy ideig a
feleségével dániában éltek ott dolgoztak
utána aztán hazaköltöztek pontosabban
volt egy kitérő budapestre ha jól
értettem igen és utána aztán
visszaköltöztél cszent királyra és akkor
elindult a ham persze nem ilyen egyszerű
mert semmi sem ilyen egyszerű úgyhogy
kezdjünk egy kicsit beszélgetni erről
elmesélnéd- hogy kerültetek ki dániába
igen én az alapképzésst a szapiencia
egyetemen végeztem marketing szakon és
ez a vásárhelyi vagy a cikzeredai nem
csikszeredai akkor indult 2010-ben
indult az első marketing szok igazából
úgy voltam én hogy nagyon szerettem a a
történelmi vonalat szerettem volna egy
kicsit ott
elhelyezkedni viszont kolozsváron volt
ilyen lehetőség valamiért nem úgy nem
úgy alakult de nem is bánom
természetesen utólag és é csik
szeradában éltem úgyhogy itthon is
maradtam felvételztem a marketing szakra
akkor egy népetát gyakorlatilag betelt
még ilyen várolista is volt úgyhogy egy
ilyen nagy nagy impulzusokkal nagy
elvárásokkal indultasok és a második év
sőt a harmadik évnek az első félében
volt egy lehetőség pontosabban az utolsó
fél évben volt egy lehetőség egy a velux
hogyha ismerős a velux így van az
ablakgyártó cégá ők hirdettek meg egy
olyan ösztöi programot hogy közép- és
keleteurópai diákok kimehetnek tanulni
dániába pontosabban coldingba egy ilyen
fél éves olyasmi mint egy cseredak
program csak éppen nem cseredak program
hanem kaptált egy egy költségvetés
megpályáztod kimentél és fél évig
gyakorlatilag tudtál tanulni és ott élni
tapasztalni és ez a tapasztalás által
úgy döntettünk akkor már a párommal
mentünk együtt ki most már feleségem és
úgy döntöttünk hogy visszamegyünk és a
mesteri képzést ott fogjuk elvégezni
közben volt egy év szüná amikor itthon
voltunk ő még szociológiát végzett
mellette és felvételeztünk a m képzésel
sikerült kettő éves mesteri képzésen
vettünk részt ott spóti és
eseménymenedzsment
szakon majd gyakorlatilag két és fél év
után nyilván mellette a mesteri mellett
dolgoztunk meg nagyon sok kapcsolatot
sikerült építeni különböző külföldi
diaktársokkal és 2 és fél után jött egy
ilyen lehetőség hogy magyarországra
hívták a páromat hogy a végtózoknál
dolgozzon ez az egy klasszikus zenei
tehetségkutató műsor tényleg ez az a
virtualok igen így van így van annyi
hogy nem a műsor részével hanem a a
backoficeb dolgoztunk ami azt jelentette
hogy tehetséggondozás koncertszervezés
satöbbi satöbbi és így így kerültünk
budapestre én is egy hónap után jöttem
utána ugyanott elhelyezkedtem és kettő
évig kicsivel tbb mint kettő évig éltünk
budapesten és dolgoztunk hát az egy
ilyen kemény
hát szinte 024-es történet voltam kevés
hét szabad hétvégével kevés kevés
szabadidővel de nagyon sok
tapasztalattal tehát tény hogy maga a
munka az egy az egy nagyon kemény abba
mondjuk abba az életszakaszba azt
mondhattom így visszatekintve hogy egy
hasznos hasznos kettő plusz év volt
viszont most nem csinálnám nyilván tehát
család mellett ez ez egy ilyen nem tudom
egy
egy tragédiával égne fel hogy ilyen
ilyen szinten reggeltől estig meg
hétvégéket meg mindent ezt a párodal
együtt tehát ő is ugyanígy dolgozott ez
közelebb vitt titeket vagy pedig pont
hogy megpróbálta a kapcsolatotokat mi
alapvetően szeretünk nagyon együtt
dolgozni tehát az egyetemen is minden
különböző esettanulmányversenyekre
játunk meg a különböző szakmai
programokban együtt vettünk részt
úgyhogy együtt dolgozni szerettünk
szerettünk is ilyen szempontból azt
mondhatom hogy közelebb hozott viszont
volt ak olyan generált olyan konfliktus
helyzeteket ami ami amit nehéz volt
kezelni mert sok volt tehát ugye a
stressz magas volt nagyon nem nagyon nem
volt időnk egymásra gyakorlatilag és és
emiatt azért ilyen kettős kettős égzés
volt bennünk folyamatosan olyan
szempontból hogy együtt voltunk egy
hájen voltunk jó volt mert szerettünk é
jól működik a közöt így így szakmailag
is a
kapcsolatunk viszont voltak olyan dolgok
amik amik nyilván hátrán hátránynak
éltünk meg ühüm igen hát a az egyik
kérdés bennem az az hogy gyakorlatilag
két lépésből hazaköltöztetek a
kicsi hazánkba miért tehát hogy ott van
dánia egy egy magas életszínvonalú
életet élhettetek máris legalábbis
láthattatok mag magatok előtt hogy ha
ott maradnátok akkor mi lenne talán a
jövőtök és budapest is egy nagyváros
tehát miért költöztetek vissza egy
kisvárosba úgy költöztünk mi má ki hogy
haz költ tehát ez volt a cél az volt a
cél hogyha most kimegyünk dániába
költözünk elvégezzük a mesteri
képzést nyilván benne volt hogy még
plusz pár év mert talán anyagilag is
kicsit stabilizálni hazajönni itt is
valahol valamivel el kell kezdeni de
hogy hazajövünk tehát azt hiszem ez az
elhatározás a legfontosabb hogy hogy
bármi van akkor haza költözünk azért
fontos nekünk család itthon volt mondjuk
a bátyámak is akkor még kint éltek
angliában
de azon kí a család itthon volt a
barátok nagyon sokan itthon voltak
úgyhogy ez a kis kis mikroközesssségünk
itt volt és folyamatosan tartottuk is a
kapcsolatot és volt egy egyetemi
tanárunk aki aki azt mondta
hogy az egyik fú nem is tudom már milyen
szak milyen tantárgy volt és
kifejezetten emlékszem erre az egy egy
mondatára hogy
szociológiailag van egy ilyen hét éves
hatá amikor azt mondod hogyha külföldön
élsz akkor még az első hét évben még
könnyű visszailleszkedni tehát hogyha
hazajössz megvannak még azok a
kapcsolatok főleg ha ápolod is akkor
viszonylag könnyű a visszailleszkedés
utána már egyre nehezebb és utána már
egyre kevésbé égzi az ember
statisztikailag ki van mutatva hogy
akkor már sokkal kisebb eséllyel
költeözik vissza a szülő hazájába és ez
is sok szór lebegett a szemem előtt hogy
azért van van egy hatar ahol ahon nem
kéne kicsúszni de összességében megvolt
az az elhatározás úgyhogy azért is azért
is váltottunk könnyebben dánielból
budapestre mert az máry lépcsőfok volt
gyakorlatilag budapest már így féligö
vol így van így van és gyakrabban is
jártunk már má haza
és aztán onnan már nem volt egy olyan
nagy nagyon nagy lépés úgy gondolom haza
hazaköltözni 2018 végén 18-ban í van mi
történt 18
után 2018-ban hogy
hazaköltöztünk az egy ilyen hát elég
fekete év volt tehát gyakorlatilag úgy
is úgy is hivat hivatkozom mindig rá
hogy az egy az egy olyan év volt ami nem
hogy más választásunk nem volt de ott
megmutatta hogy tényleg hol a helyünk
tehát h tényleg édesapám meghalt abb az
évben nagyon sok közeli
ismerősünk barátunknak a közeli
hozzátartozója tehát ilyen egy kicsit
szürreális volt az egész
hogy mi miért történik és és valahogy
valahogy ez egy ilyen egy olyan
buborékot képezett amiből úgy éreztük
hogy nagyon nagyon nagyon otthon kell
most legyünk úgyhogy ez is volt egy
trigger de alapvetően már úgy is
terveztük teehát 18 elején már lejüttünk
volt az akkori az akkori főnökünkkel és
beszélgettünk az akkor meggyőzött hogy
még azért maradjunk de ittal nem volt
kérdés 18 közepén hogy akkor
hazaköltözünk és a hiszem szeptemberben
költöztünk haza és ott volt egy ilyen
vízválasztó történet hogy nyilván el
kéne helyezkedni itthon é dolgozni
valamit már ak azelőtt megszületett egy
ilyen vágy hogy szeretnék vállalkozni
érdekes én nekem nekem ilyen fiat
kiskoroman vagy fiatalkoromban nem volt
meg ez a ez az intuíció hogy most én
vállalkozó szeretnék lenni voltak ilyen
képzeteim hogy lesz egy lovag de má
szerettem a lovakat meg hasonló de nem
volt meg bennem ez hogy én most
vállalkozni fogok
viszont úgy dániában ugye hogy azt a
gyakorlatiasságot láttam azt a
vállalkozói környezetet ahogy támogatják
a vállalkozásokat az intézmények és az
állam is akkor hogy megszületett hogy hú
hát jó lenne otthon is vállalkozni
valamit hisz itt gyűjtünk tapasztalatot
és nézzük meg hogy mit lehetne kihozni
belőle és akkor h megszületett egy ilyen
egy ilyen döntés úgymond hogy otthon
otthon csinálunk egy egy ügynökséget a
nyugati ügynökségek mintájára ami azt
eleli fel
hogy különböző szolgáltatásokat
biztosítunk cégeknek grafikai marketing
és fejlesztés web és abfejlesztés
szolgáltatásokat úgyhogy ez így ez így
már megszületett és dániában
ismerkedtünk meg a az egyik a
cégtársamnak barátomnak a a párjával aki
akivel aztán úgy szöbödtek a kapcsolatok
hogy együtt is alapítottuk meg a céget
és 201 az amikor hazaköltöztünk ez volt
egy nagy dilemma hogy akkor akkor most
elhelyezkedni akkor már kerestem én is
munkát de hogy szerettem volna
vállalkozást is indítani közben mikor
még magyarországon értünk volt egy
pályázata startup pályázat keretén belül
konkrétan egy az egyik alapítvány a
lámalapítvány sorov együtt meghirdettek
egy egy ilyen diaszpó pályázatot ami azt
jelenti hogy aki olyanoknak hdették meg
akik magyarországon élnek ma legalább
egy egy éve és itthon akarnak
vállalkozást alapít hazaköltezni ez egy
az egybe tehát ez ilyen úgy voltam vele
hogy azért jó lenne egy stabil munkahely
de ez ez ilyen nagyon célzott volt tehát
ez nem lehetett véletlen én amúgy se
hiszek a
véletlenekbe és vágtam akkor az
eredményt tehát akkor már fél éve ment a
dolog megvt a képzés leadtam a
pályázatot de azért csak nem lehetett
hónapokig ülni a végimon de mellette
voltak már ilyen kis projektek akkor már
csináltunk egy céget közben hogy hogy ak
azért ha vannak ilyen kisebb projektek
akkor tudjuk ezeket teljesíteni és aztán
191 végén jött a jött a határozat hogy
akkor sikerült megnyerni ezt a
pályázatot és 19 áprilisában indítottuk
el a indítottuk el a céget
április már nem tudom hányadikán de
talán május 3m-án az arra jól emlékszem
akkor költöztünk be az irodába először
2019-ben és innen
itt először külsős projektekkel kezdtünk
foglalkozni nyilván tehát kellett
kellett egy bizonyos
hát a túlélésér azért kellett dolgozni
mellette már már ugye a hamnak a a
koncepciója megszületett sokkal hamarabb
ekkor kezdtünk foglalkozni vele és
akkor kezdett érdekessé válni a helyzet
amikor úgy kifutott a pályázat és és úgy
elfogyott a pénz
gyakorlatilag itt azért a hallgató
kedvére azért felhoznám azt a azt az
emléket amikor meglátogattalak és
leültünk beszélgetni akkor még tartott a
pályázat és beszélgettünk a a jövőbeli
tervekről és én emlékszem hogy óvatosan
azért megemlítetted a hammot is mint egy
ilyen potenciális lehetőség én személy
szerint nagyon lelkes voltam mert
ugyancsak a hallgatók kedvéért így
röviden elmondom hog ez az informatikai
piac egy nagyon érdekes piac mert ott
van a lehetősége a a skálázhatósága az
informatikának ami gyakorlatilag azt
jelenti hogy ha most egyszer legyártunk
valamit akkor gyakorlatilag szintezíró
költséggel lehet azt a valamit újra és
újra és újra felhasználni és emlékszem
hogy az exarlpsen belül is leültünk és
sokszor gondolkoztunk azon hogy mit
lehetne csinálni pont ugyanígy hogy
amikor lejárt egy projekt és
felszabadult valaki hogy mihez mihez
tudnánk hozzányúlni sőt akkor még kicsit
álmodoztunk arról hogy a nemzetközi
piacon milyen jó lenne egy szoftvert
megírni és akkor eladnánk és akkor hogy
hogy hogy honnan jöhetne be pénz persze
ez időközben kiderült hogy egy naiv
gondolat volt tehát hogy egy
hihetetlenül kompetitív piac egyrészt az
informatika piac másrészt pedig nagyon
nagyon nagyon nagyon nehéz valamit
eladni tehát hogy maga az ötlet ha még
ki is van vitelezve azt látom még az sem
tehát az az 5%-a körülbelül a munkának
és a utána jön a maga a marketing utána
jön maga a a a a kapcsolatok a különböző
cégekkel a a kapcsol ksolattartás és
rengetegrengeteg kérdés van amiről
szeretnék veled beszélgetni mert
valójában azt amit mi álmodtunk és
rájöttünk hogy irreális tehát hogy nem
nem nem vagyunk még felkészülve arra
hogy egy saját terméket hozzunk létre te
ezt ezt az utat jártad be valójában és
ezt szeretném egy kicsit végigbeszélni
veled hogy hogyan az elindulástól kezdve
2019-től kezdve most pontosabban 18-tól
kezdve már akkor a hamnak az ötlete
megvolt mi történt egészen most 2024-ig
így lépésről lépésre kezdjünk el egy
kicsit beszélgetni róla
és a másik alapelv amit amit szeretnék
átbeszélni hogy lássam hogy te is így
látod-e gyakorlatilag azt látom hogy a
terv és a megvalósítás között van egy
hihetetlen nagy szakadék tehát hogyha
most kéne súlyozni akkor ötöt adnék a
tervre és 95%-ot adnék a vagy 95-öt
adnék a megvalósításra sőt lehet hogy a
hamnál még kisebb lenne lehet hogy egy a
terv és 99 a a megvalósítás és ez ez
érvényes mindenhol tehát hogyha el
kezdünk valamit tervezni vagy legyen az
egy szék vagy legyen ez egy bármi amit
amit mert mindent kétszer alkotunk van
egy van egy tervezési fázis és egy
kivitelezési fázis mindig aránytalanul
kevés kevesebb a terv és mindig
aránytalanul nagyobb a kivitelezés
ennyire komplex a világunk és emiatt is
van bennem egyre inkább az hogy egy jó
tervet megosztani
másokkal nem kell félni attól hogy
megosszuk a terveinket mert egyrészt
honnan tudjuk hogy a tervünk tényleg
olyan jó tehát hogyha csak úgy elgetjük
magunkban meg rejtegetjük akkor akkor
nem derül ki de ha megosztjuk másokkal
akkor mások tudnak rá reflektálni de ha
félünk attól hogy mások ellopják azt a
tervet akkor pont ez a válasz rá hogy
nagyon-nagyon nehéz valamit ellopni és
kivitelezni szóval szinte lehetetlen
hogy most valaki csak úgy fogja a mi
víziónkat és megvalósítja helyettünk
úgyhogy térjünk vissza 2018-ra amikor
már alakulgatott a ham íy a fejedbe
és kicsit mesélj nekünk arról hogy
hogyan lépett piacra ez a hám mi történt
ott a
háttérben visszennék a kezdetekre
danánielbaan éltünk
és
elnézést és akkor talán akkor rendeltem
először azt hiszem a just it volt ott a
akkor a piacon a legnagyobb most is just
it tk v talán ösze vanon öszeltek vonva
akkor elem először és kezdtem gondolozni
hogy otthon otthon ilyen nincsen tudom
hogy egy budapesten vagy bukarest
kolozsvárg itt már kezdett
gyökere lenni de hogy otthon nincsen
ilyen és milyen jó lenne otthon
megcsinálni azt végül is hogy nem egy
nagy dolog nem tehát hogy gyakorlatilag
egy applikáció így van és az emberek
letöltik s rendelnek az ét termektől
ugye nyilván nem ilyen egyszerű
és akkor budapesten ez már
sokszorosan láttuk hogy ez egy nagyon
jól működő modell mi is nagyon sokat
rendeltünk ugye időhiányában főzni alig
főztünk tehát gyakorlatilag
olyan is volt ebédet vagy sorát
rendeltünk úgyhogy ez is ez is
megerősítet enk hogy hogy azért szükség
van ez egy olyan hiánypótló történet
amire szükség van itt van még azért
bőven bőven az volt hogy az emberek
felhívták az étternekegy telefonon
megrendeltük a pizzát vagy napiendőt
vagy bármit nem volt erre még megoldás
és amikor
201 talán 17-ben kezdtünk beszélgetni
erről szabival akkor már a cégtársammal
és és egyetérrtetk abban hogy ezt meg
kell csinálni tehát ezt ezt amikor úgy
lehetőség van rá akkor meg kell csinálni
és amikor elindítottuk a céget 19-ben
akkor már neki is fogtunk volt egy kis
piaackutatás azzal kapcsolatban hogy mi
legyen a neve milyen színeket
használjunk
azt hiszem ez meg pont ott találkoztunk
mutattál pár variánst már nekem igen
igen igen igen igen igen igen voltak
érdekességek aztán és azért volt jó hogy
ezt ezt egy kicsit meg meg meg kér talán
volt egy ilyen 100-200-as minta akikkel
így a közvetlen környezetünkből akikkel
ezt így kitöltettük egy egy egyszerű
google űrlap azért volt ez jó meg
kértünk szakmai véleményt is mert lehet
hogy nem lehet hogy akkor nem itt
lennénk nem ez választottuk volna és nem
lett volna ennyire ennyire sikeres ennek
a brandnek a az építkezése de talán ez
ez az egyik legfontosabb hogy validálni
tudtunk egy egy ötletet egy logót milyen
színeket használak tehát tulajdonképpen
ez ez ez ez hogy a piac azt mondta hogy
oké ez ez így szerintem én ezt
választanám tehát hogyha kell ez a három
vagás közü választani én ezt választanám
és közben kezdtük fejleszteni az
alkalmazást és nyilván nem a spanyol
viaszt akartuk feltalálni megnéztük a a
netpincékt akkor még nem akkor már de
akkor még nem volt brandáltás mer azt
hiszem pont 18 után lett megnéztük a
netp izét a glovót talán de megnéztük a
különböző multiknak az alkalmazásait
és ami fontos volt hogy próbáltunk
kicsit a helyi piacra is
a fejlesztéseket ráhúzni tehát tegyük
fel betettünk egy napi menü modult ami
máshol nem volt tehát egy egy multi
multinál tehát egy foodpandában vagy
netpinzben nem volt olyan hogy napi menü
de nálunk ez egy mai napig egy nagyon
elterjedt és nagyon
népszerű modul mert az emberek fellépnek
sokkal egyszerűbb mint bengézgetni egy
csomó külön éttelmeket megnézni és az
alakából kiválasztani hanem van egy napi
menő sor ráklikkelsz megrendeled és
nálunk még ez a leves főétel akár
desszert kombináció ez még elég
jellemzően
hatékony meg az emberek szeretik ezt még
ez a kis vasárnapi ebéd feelingje van és
2019-től ahogy elkezdtük fejleszteni
igazából 2020
februárjában raktuk ki először en play
store app storeba tehát akkor volt a
publikáció de
eközött már ősszel elkezdtünk hát
gyakorlatilag fogtam a táskámat é mentem
a különböző itmekhez hogy van egy ilyen
lehetőség hát nem kell mondjam hog a
legtöbb helyen egyet mosolyoktak és azt
mondták hogy ez pont erről akarok egy
kicsit kérdezni szóval a ami
megfogalmazóott benne kérdésként az az
hogy hogy amit látunk az az hogy egy
ipari korszakból áthaladunk éppen egy
információs korszakba tehát hogy
udvarhely és és gyakorlatilag a régiónk
pont ebbe a tranzíóba van azt jelenti
hogy a nagy része a cégeknek még mindig
ipari korszakban él és akkor vannak
cégek akik lassan átmennek és erről
akartam kérdezgetni hogy hogy hogy te
ezt hogyan tapasztaltad mennyire voltak
nyitottak és hogy az elmúlt négy évben
mennyit lazult ez a helyzet nagyon
nagyon nehéz volt nagyon nehéz volt az
az első szerződéseket
megkötni volt hogy több körös tárgyalás
volt pedig egyszerű tehát nálunk nem nem
árultunk akkor se zsákbacskát adtunk
két-három hónapos próbaidőszakot hogy
lássák hogy ez mi is lássuk egyáltalán
az nyilván hogy minél több partnerünk
legyen és hogy az az ötlet az
valid de azon kívül jutalékos
rendszerben dolgozunk nem kell nincsenek
fix költségek hanem rendelésenként x
összeg jutalék tehát nem nem az volt
hogy elak akartunk adni és akkor ki
kellett fizessen valamennyit és vagy
megtérő vagy nem neki hanem
gyakorlatilag hogyha rendelés van akkor
akkor fizetutá és ennek ellenére sem
tudtunk
egyből nagy számú
partnerekkel szerződni voltak
nyitottabbak tehát volt olyan hogy
bementünk és azt 10 perc azt mondtá oké
hol a szerződés alajiktok kitöltöttük
vittem magammal hogy 50 kinyomtató
szerződést ügyesen írtuk be az adatokat
de nehéz volt
először szeredáb kezdtük el a az
értékesítést akkor még én meg
szabiárogattunk a különböző partnerekhez
és összegyűlt egy olyan 8-10 8-10
partner akivel elindultunk hányat
kerestetek meg hogy nyolc t összegyűljön
hát nagyon sokat ilyen gyakorlatilag
szinte mindenkiit tehát biztos hogy 20
fölött de hogy ez a 810 is úgy gyűlt
össze hogy utó utánkövetés
telefonálgatás na akkor gondolkodtál
csináljuk ne csináljuk jó lesz gyere
tehát igazából ez a ez a típusú nekem
nem volt érdkes és tapasztaltam
egyáltalán de sokat tanultam ezáltal és
amikor összegyűlt ez a ez a 810 partner
úgy voltunk hogy akkor próbáljuk meg
tegyük ki ind induljon el emlékszem hogy
talán február t volt 201 220-baan és
ültünk
úgy gondoltuk egy nagy dobás lesz és
ültünk a az evédlőbe így az asztal körül
és kiraktuk szépen na hány rendelésen be
hány regisztráció ugy regisztrációk
gyűltek egyébként tehát a nap végére a
100 plusz regisztráció lett de íy az
első rendésre valami délutánig kellett
vágni és a pezsgők így ki voltak tve úgy
voltunk hogy na akkor most ez ez ez egy
új igazából igazunk volt mer tényleg egy
új mégföldkő volt a
cégéletébe és aznap talán 10 10 rendelés
jött be de csalódottak voltatok igen azt
azt mondhatom én kifejezetten az voltam
és nem vágtam csodát
de de úgy voltam vele hogy ez egy olyan
dolog ami amire szükség van az
embereknek és és próbáltuk ezt ezt promó
kimentá próbáltuk ezt hirdetni hogy na
fiú indul egy indul egy ilyen történet
és látva a nagyvárosokban hogy hogy
működik ez a piac úgy voltam vele hogy
biztos hogy ez ez robbanni fog na hát
nem n robbant hanem
lehet jobb is hanem szépen lépcsőzetesen
kezdett épülni aztán a következő nap még
néhány rendeléssel több lett és még jött
a következő egy-két hónapban még jöttek
partnerek és akkor ugye március közepén
bejütött itt a covid h
és legtöbben az az érdekes hogy így
utólag sokan kérdezik hogy na hát
gyakorlatilag annak a
hatásara milyen jót tett nekünk és az
érdekes hogy visszanézve a számokat nem
nem volt egy robbanás tehát nem nem
mondhatjuk azt hogy most hirtelen volt
30 rendelés március 9-én vagy 14-én
mázem 15-étő zartták le és akkor 15-én
lett
300 hanem fokozatos volt tehát
ugyanolyan ütemben jött a növekedés
nyilván hozzá segített mert nem lehetett
kimenni akkor volt merkuris partnerünk
volt bevásárlásokat tudtak intézni
rajtunk keresztül
de igazából azzal azon keresztül jött a
növekedés hogy a partnereink száma
szépen szépen kúszott
föelé és kezdett az igény megjelenni
nyáron hogy hát nem nem akartak
szállítás szolgáltatást indítani nem
volt elk be az elején tudtuk hogy ez egy
elég nagy adminisztrációs logisztikai
történet de mivel meg vololt az igény rá
úgy voltunk vele hogy kellőszámú partner
esetén elindítjuk el is
indítottuk és utána gyakorlatilag azon a
nyáron ha jólémlik már gyergyobba is
kezdtünk terjeszkedni kaptunk egy a
megfelelő embert megtaláltuk és még most
is
most is ő gyergyobb a úgynevezett
városmenedzserünk aki aki tényleg azt
gondolom hogy az egyik legfontosabb
része az volt hogy megtaláltuk a
megfelelő embereket a megfelelő
pozíciókra és udvarhelyen is elindultunk
és akkor kezdtünk így terjeszkedni
kezdtük gyógni nyilván voltak voltak
minden városban ismerősek barátok akik
segítettek ebben van egy éttelmes
ismerős sem kérdezzük meg jó lesz és és
ak így gyűltek a partnerek és ah gyűltek
a partnerek hoggy gyűltek a regisztrálók
és gyűltek a rendelések is folyamatosan
gyanítom hogy most már könnyebb
meggyőzni egy partnert hogy
bizonyítottatok a piacon a név már
ismerős mindenkinek igen igen hát most
már nem mondhatom nem megyünk mi az
éttermekhez hogy megfordult ez a igen
megfordult gyakorlatilag a van nagyon
sok olyan partnerünk van aki az utóbbi
két évben indította el a egy legyen egy
büfékocsi vagy egy kis étterem vagy egy
kifőz a bármi és első körben minket
keresett meg hogy fog indulni körülbelül
két-három hónap múlva és már előre
megkeresett és vannak tényleg olyan
partnerek akik gyakorlatilag azért
tudtak fennmaradni covid alatt is mert
mert a hammon tudtak értékesíteni és úgy
gondolom hogy ez egy ezt egy viszonylag
nagy sikernek tudom megélni hisz adtunk
egy adtunk egy botot a kezükbe amire
tudtak támaszkodni és nyilván hogy lehet
annyira volt elég hogy éppen éppen
kihúzzák ezt az időszakot de de túléltek
és volt aki nem élt túl a piacon de
vannak akik pont ezélt elképesztő most
hány partneretek van most hát 200 plusz
most már most már ott tartunk ugye
harrita megyében csikszereda
gyergyaszentmiklós székelyudvarhely
székelykeresztul és kavászna megyében
pedig
sepsizentgyörgy kézdivás hely úgyhogy
haita a kovászna megye az le van fedve
eléggé most maros megyében indultunk
talán három hete ott még van munka jó
bőven de de bízunk benne hogy ott is egy
jó szeletet ki tudunk szakítani ebből a
piacból hisz az a célunk úgy gondolom
hogy megvan annak ellenére hogy ott
megvannak a multik megvannak a
versenytársak de nekünk is megvan az
erőségünk akár milyen kicsik vagyunk is
ebbe a ebbe a játékba és most a
megrendelések számát tekintve hol
tartottak biztos van egy pontos
statisztikád arról hogy napi rendelésbe
vagy heti rendelésbe hány jön be
nap naponta körülbelül egy ilyen 2000
rendelést megy végig rajtunk és nyilván
az folyamatosan változik tehát vannak
olyan időszakok amikor az október tehát
szeptemberoktóbertől márciusig tartó
időszakba
több több általában tehát van egy ilyen
éve amikor elkezdődik az iskola jön az
ősz kevesebbet tudnak már nem olyan jó
az idő nem ülnek ki az emberek inkább
rendelnek otthon és december talán
decemberben csúcsosodik de január
február március egy nagyon erős hónap
pont azok a hónapok erősek házho
szállításban amikor
amikor amikor nem annyian nem üln tehát
annyian nem mennek ki az éttermekbe ugye
nyáron nagyon sokan vannak ott a terasz
teraszokat kiteszik tehát akkor
nagyon-nagyon perök viszont ekkor ekkor
már statisztikailag
az történik hogy kicsit csekken az étnek
a forgalma ősztől tavaszig nyilván az
ünnepek meg vannak ezek a különböző
időszakok amikor szintén felfut de
összességében összességében kiegészíti
pont ez a
hasuszáíás piac aztermeknek ezt a ezt a
hiányát és van egy ilyen nyári időszak
ami áprilistól augusztusig amikor nem
mondanám hogy csökken viszont van egy
stagnálás tehát edig mindig volt egy
ilyen lépcsőzetes növekedés aztán itt
van egy stagnálás ami ami nem csökkenést
hoz hanem egy ilyen fix történetet ugye
szabadságolások nagyon sokan amúgy
munkába irodábaan rendellnek és ilyenkor
amikor jönnek a szabadságok a nyári
időszak kijönnek teraszra
akkor akkor nyilván már nincs meg ez a
növekedés de van egy van egy stabil van
egy stabil szám amit mindig tudunk hozni
úgyhogy
úgyhogy most már így a statisztika
alapján elmondható hogy ez egy elég
stabil piac lett itt a két két h hol
érzed azt a váltást amikor úgy érzed
hogy ez meg meglépetek egy mérföldkövet
most már stabilabb inkább már látod a
jövőt mintogy hogy nem látod hány
rendelésnél jött iligen igazából hogy
nem is a rendelés szám hol hol tudod
megfogni ezt nem is a rendelés számok
hanem talán
2022 tavasza volt az amikor megfordult
az egész addig tényleg sokáig az volt
hogy túléltünk mindig egyik hónaprra a
másikra azért húztuk hol pluszos hol
mínuszos de nagyjából itt a nulla kerül
konvergáltuk egy nagyon pici profittal
de tényleg elenyésző és
akkor jötünk rá hogy valamit tennünk
kell mert azutána nem lesz fenntartható
és akkor vezettük be a szállítási díjat
tehát akkor addig picit tartottunk attól
hogy most ha szállítási díjat fogunk
felszámolni akkor vajon mennyit fogunk
veszíteni
de nem is volt nagyon ennek
hogy mondjam az az éttermek és
legtöbbször a szállítási díjat bele aki
magának szállított belekalkulálta a az
ételeknek az árába a menünknek az árából
és azért az ember azt látta hogy ne
nincs szállítási díj gyakorlatilag van
egy kis csomagolási díj és és akkor
nyilván onnan rendel ahol nincs
szállítási díj de mindenhol az volt
tehát minden platformon az volt a
jellemző hogy van szállítási díj
természetesen és rájöttünk hogy hát ha
nem változtatunk valamin akkor akkor nem
tehát hosszú távon ezt lehet cs álni
csak akkor nincs nagyon értelme nem
tudunk fejlődni és akkor vezettük be a
szállítási díjat akkor fordult meg és
akkor tudtunk tényleg a szállítási
szolgáltatásnak a fejlesztésére is
fókuszt fordítani akkor tudtunk tényleg
a a backoffist-t is fejleszteni egyre
jobban akkor fordult át tényleg hogy
fokozatosan pluszos tudott maradni és
azért szerintem azért azért nagy azér is
nagy dolog ez mert a multik elkezdve
glovo most foodóra tehát bármik multit
megnézzük t az mínusz nagyon-nagyon
mínuszosak tehát ez egy olyan olyan piac
ahol a folyamatosan nyomják bele a tőkét
folyamatosan az
ügyfélszerzésbe és meg a fejlesztésbe és
emiatt gyakorlatilag mindig mínuszon
tartják tehát olyan meg lehet nézni hogy
a mondjuk a romániai glovo cégnek milyen
milyen számai vannak tehát elképesztően
nagy veszteségeket produkál és azt
gondolom hogy kicsiként nem is t
választta mert bár volt egy-két kisebb
befektetésünk de nem volt túl sok
választásunk azzal kapcsolatba hogy hogy
mi ezt hosszútávon nem tudjuk még
nullásan se csinálni mert ugye a
költségek nőnek folyamatosan
azért bármilyen tehát szállítási
eszközökkel kapcsolatos költségek is
nőnek autók biciklik tehát bármiről
beszélünk tényleg van egy ilyen
növekedés hogyha nem tartjuk ezzel a
lépést akkor meg nem lesz esélyünkm
úgyhogy azt gondolom hogy az egy pozitív
valamon pozitív dol egy kicsit
beszélgessünk erről a a a piacról mert
meséltél el arról hogy itt a multik
gondolom itt a a glovo az egyik és a
másik a a volt food panda is most mi is
a neve még egyszer hát a glovo meg most
a taz van egyébként a piacon aki most a
bolt food is romániáb elindult
bocsánat de az volt hogy a volot a glovo
és a fut panda
aztán a glovo a futpandának a
balkánpiacát felvásárolta aztán a glovot
felvásárolta a futpanda anyacége deát
ezek ezek ilyen jó kis játékok voltak
ami leosztották egymás köz gyakorlatilag
a piacot most peg pillanat a glovo és a
tas van akik a legerősebbek a a piacon
de ott van még a bolt food aki a
nagyvárosokban már kezdett megerősödni
gyakortilag ezek a játékosok akik úgy
országszinten labdába rognak és nemzet
szinten vagy európai szinten európai
szinten is európai szinten talán még ott
a volt ugye ott magyarországról ismerhet
ők ők egy fincék üüm de azt hiszem őket
is föásárolta az amerikai dashdor mintha
és
és európai szinten gyakorlatilag a a
glovo uralja ugye a dél-európai zónát
tehát azt a mediterrán térséget és a
foodóra meg nyugat-európában van a justy
t kövej tehát ők ők a nagyobb játékosok
már a nyugat és észak-európai szintéren
dél-amerika nagyjából glovo ázsia
foodóra tehát ezek ezek a piacok
nagyjából úgy le vannak osztva vagy
akarva akaratlan hogy minden minden
régióban van egy erős játékos és van
egy-két erősebb versenytárs és a kicsik
nem nagyon tudnak labdába rugni tehát
ott vagy nagyhal kisale effektus megeszi
a nagyhal a kishalat vagy az van hogy
egyszerűen nem nem tud hosszú tá é ha
jól tudom titeket is is a futpandal fel
akart vásárolni valamikor hát
megkerestek volt kiderült hogy nem volt
egy túl komoly igazából egy ilyen kicsit
megfélemlítés szaga volt az egésznekm
lejöltünk egy három órát tárgyaltunk de
gyakorlatilag a 90%-ában az volt a a
foodpandás ügyneknek az volt
folyamatosan a a mondandója hogy nem
nagyon van itt esélyünk jönnek tényleg
jó bjjük van nyilván egy nagy brand
szerintte ezt így el kéne engedni ühüm
és a az még 2022-ben volt talánm tehát
nem is nem is voltunk még olyan nagyon
nagyon nagyon erősek de de már azért ez
ez ezeken a haritegyel piacokon erősek
voltunk és akkor jelejtett egy olyan
hogy akkor
na nézzük meg hogy esetleg mennyit érne
meg nekünk az hogy mi kivonulunk a
piacról de nem tehát éreztük hogy nem is
komoly a szándék de nem is voltunk abba
a pozícióval hogy most ilyen exitekről
beszéljünk mert egyrészt szerintem
nevetséges pénzekről lehetett volna
beszélni másrészt nem akartuk az ez egy
ilyen olyan mint egy saját gyerek hogy
úgy nevelgeted és nem kön nem nem nagyon
engeded el úgy egy könnyet azóta nem
kerestek meg még nem nem nem nem nem
vagy most hogy vásárhelyen kezdtek
terjeszkedni lehet hogy beleszóltok a
piacaikba remélem hogy bele beleszólunk
és kicsit kicsit fel felkavarjuk az
allóvizet ez is a terv de kiderül úgy
vagyok vele hogy hála istennek nem
szorulunk rá hogy itt most egy akar
exitre menjünk és nagyon sokat
fektettünk abba energiát időt és pénzt
is hogy hogy fejlesszük a piacot is és
nem csak a brendet merr gyakorlatilag
piacot alakítottunk ki az egész az egész
ételkiszállítói piacot a hargita
megyében mi képeztük tehát mi
fejlesztettük nem volt edig addedig a
pontig tehát 2020-ig nem volt nem volt
jellemző ugye ez a betelefonálós
történet volt és egyáltalán nem volt a
izé terendesnek kultúrája nem volt olyan
fogyasztó is szokás nem létezett hogy
alkalmazásból rendelz és és azért amikor
egy ennyi energiát időt beleraksz akkor
akkor úgy úgy nem nagyon tudod elengedni
egy könnyen az egészet ez még mindig
kérdés számomra hogy hogyan tudtok
versenyezni a multikkal ez az egyik és
ráadásul úgy versenyezni hogy ti
profitábilisak vagytok és a multik prof
profitábilisek tehát hogy mi történik
itt hol hol hol tudtok labdába rúgni nem
nem látom még mindig a a a a a mögötte
rejlő erőt ami mozgatja vagy h hogyan
lehetséges ez hát az egyik legfontosabb
dolog az volt hogy ezeken a kis piacokon
nem volt még senki tehát hátrány is volt
hogy fel kellett építeni de előny is
volt hogy még senkit nem ismertek nem
volt ez nem volt ott egy futpanda nem
volt ott egy glovó senki nem volt a a
aki aki akin tehát ezek a telefonakon
nem volt az embereknek letöltve semmi
kivéve aki mondjuk kolozsváron
egyetemista volt vagy nagyvárosba vagy
kicsit világot látott budapesten vagy
valahol élt és ismerte ezt a ezt a
folyamatot meg ezt az
éterrendelőpiacot ez egy nagy előny volt
és amikor már beléptek ezek a az óriások
a
piacainkra
akkor nem nem én úgy g gondom azért nem
tudtak labdába rúni mert az emberek
azért márkahülyek és főleg ezen ezen a
market
marketplace piacon most megnézhetjük egy
gyamagot is akár hogy ha gyamagon
megnézel egy terméket lehet a tudatosabb
tudatosabbak azt megcsinálják hogy
megnézik hogy ki
értékesíti melyik cég rákeres a saját
webshopjára lehet ott olcsóbb 10%-kal és
ot rendel meg de a legtöbbember nem mert
azt mondja sokkal kényelmesebb hogy y
felép a zemagra bármit meg tudott
rendelni nekem is sokkal kényelmesebb
tát zemagomm nem is tudom milyen elég
nagy forgalom bonyolítottunk mi is mert
gyakorlatilag nagyon sok mindent onnan
rendelünk igen igen
és megvan ez a kényelem megvan és megvan
ez a markahűség is ha jól működik valami
van egy lojalitás iránta hogy akkor
innen már rendeltem háromszor most miért
töltsem le a másikat amúgy is kisebb a
választék sokkal kisebb a a lehetőségek
tárháza akkor inkább ezután is r ek a
hambogó tehát ennek nincs értelme hogy
más egy új helyre hogyan tudtak akkor
így bevonulni ahol már vásárhely
gondolom egy ilyen hely ahol már meg
igen vasárhelyen ott egyébként ami még
előnyünk ezeken a kis piacokon az hogy
mi próbálunk személyesen tartani a
kapcsolatot a partnereinkkel is ha
valami probléma van a
kliensekkel megoldani rögtön tehát most
ha egy multit nézünk egy glovónak a
platformját az van hogy ha valami
kimaradt a
rendelésedből gyakorlatilag azt tudod
csinálni hogy az abba megnyitott
elküldesz egy panaszt és kapsz egy vert
kimaradt egy ny les kóla kapsz egy ny ls
wert de ugye a felasználónak a
rendelőnek nem az a lényeg hogy akkor
kapja egy ny les rósekt azzal mondjuk el
van hallgattatva hanem az hogy akkor ő
meg szeretett volna inni egy hideg kólát
és mi ezt real time tehát akkor abb a
pillanatban próbáljuk minél gyorsabban
ezt az igényt kielégíteni betelefonál
oké fut a szólunk az étteremnek vagy az
ét ha az étteremnek telefoná szól nekünk
és az az egy kolával kimegyünk mert
fontos az hogy itt már nyilván az egy
veszteséges történet hegyrendeeléssel
kétszer megyünk ki de mégis csak a
kliensek a a aki rendel és aki a pénzét
otthagyja és és lojális a márkához az
egy az fontos hogy a neki az igényei úgy
legyen kielégítve ahogy ahogy mig érjük
és ahogy ő is elvárja és a partnereinket
is az van hogy folyamatosan ha valami
probléma van fel tudnak hívni
személyesen
nem csak engem nyilván hanem a
kollégákat valam segítünk nekik a
menüfeltöltésben a változtatásb
módosításba tehát rugalmasok vagyak azt
azt gondolom hogy ez az egyik
legfontosabb ismérünk és és őszinték
vagyunk hogyha valamit meg lehet oldani
megoldjuk ha valamit nem akkor azt
mondjuk hogy nem tudjuk megoldani de
közeljbben lehet hogy ez megoldható lesz
és az új piacon ez még egy nagyon új
helyzet nekünk mert ugye harita megyében
mindenhol mi mi indítottuk kovászna
megyében ott az
ospetágót vettük meg tehát ott ott egy
olyan ott már ti voltatok a nagy halak
ott már lehet így is nevezni amúgy
nagyon szépen felépítették szentgyörgen
az oszpetágó és mi már
2021-ben meg is ismerkedtünk a az
oszpetának tulajdonosaival sőt mint
kiderült később a nálunk a mi
szomszédjainknak a a a sógora meg a
testvére tehát gyakorlatilag olyan olyan
érdekes nyítam a füvecs láttam hogy ne
ott van izé csanád az a petáos és
ott már kialakult egy bizalmi kapcsolat
és úgy is kerestünk meg hogy ne
szeretnénk terjeszkedni
gondoltunk arra hogy itt itt egy
felvásárlásról beszélgethetnénk és az az
érdekes hogy ők is elmondták amikor
leültünk tárgyalni hogy ők is úgy voltak
hogy valahogy van ez a plafonálódás is
és ahhoz hogy fejlődni lehessen kell egy
kicsit
tergeszkedni tehát akkor együtt fej
fejlődtök tovább vagy kivásároltátok
őket kivásároltuk kivásároltuk ettől
független még működtetjük a az özpetáró
platformot mert egy annyira erős helyi
brend hogy azért az átregisztrálás azért
viszonylag lassan megy sokkal
gyorsabbnak terveztük de de van egy
ilyen van egy ilyen lojalitás és nyilván
megvnak az eszközök amivel így neveljük
ezt a a az átregisztrációt de nem is így
utólag nem is probléma mert mert azt
gondolom hogy ha azt mondjuk hogy két
hónap alatt folyamatosan
kommunikálhatttuk volna hogy két hónap
múlva megszűnik az ospitágó akkor nagyon
sokat veszítettünk volna így volt
például a a glovo amikor a fut pandát
itt átvette ezt a piacot azt hiszem hogy
két vagy három hónap volt amíg amíg ők
váltottak és azzal a váltással azért
ugye a partnereinkkel beszélgetve sokat
veszik k meg a fut pandától voltak
rendeléseik de ahogy ahogy a glovóra ogy
hítelen átváltott úgy gyakorlatilag így
így zuhanó repülésbe
ment az egész piac
számukra és nagyon-nagyon küszködnek
most is úgyhogy ilyen szempontból ezért
is tartottuk fontosnak hogy ezt
megtartsuk és tényleg fokozatosan
próbáljuk ezt ezt átdolgozni az újpiacon
meg vásárhelyen ott ott egyértelműen
megvan ott tudjuk hogy csak
úgy lehet labdábarogni hogyha
megszólítjuk konkrétan az embereket hogy
hogy ott ott még a partnereknek
a a begyűjtése úgymond a
szerződéskötéseken még kell dolgozzunk
de összességében azért úgy nyitottabbak
mert van két-három platform ahol jelen
vannak és a s há most már tényleg egy
harmadik negyedik az az összességében
nem árt hogyha van
viszont nem titok hogy szeretnénk a
magyar közessséget megszólítani tehát
hogyha valamiben labdába tudunk rogni
akkor az az hogy legalább egy réteget
megszólítsunk azért elég nagy a
magyarközöég igen és senki nem
kommunikál nekik mondjuk magyar nyelven
például és természetesen ugyanúgy fontos
a románpiac is tehát a a román
felhasználók de hogyha valamivel el
tudunk indulni akkor az az hogy hogy
tényleg erre fektessünk hangsúlyt hogy
na itt vagyunk a ti nyelv eken a ti
stílusotokba abba a környezetbe
kommunikálunk és igyekszünk minőség
szolgáltatást adni és és ezzel próbáljuk
növelni ott a a jelenlétünket ha tetszik
ez az epizód akkor kérlek iratkozz fel a
csatornánkra vagy írd meg kommentbe hogy
milyen más témáról hallanál még szívesen
így a kicsit kérdeznék a számokról is
ugyanis azt látom hogy a paretto elv az
egy az egy természeti törvény ez a
paretto elv a nézőkked kedvéér ez a
8020-as szabály
hogy például a klasszikus zenék piacán
öt zeneszerzőtől játszanak szinte minden
klasszikus zenét ez a bu bitoven mzart
hogyha most a focistákról beszélgetünk
egy szűk kisebbsége a focistáknak rúgja
a túlnyomó többségét a goloknak tehát ez
a folyókra érvényes tehát a folyóknak a
hozama hogyha megnézzük romániábaan az
összes folyóból egy szűk kisebbsége a
folyónak annyi folyóknak annyi
vízhozammal rendelkezik mint az es többi
és gyakorlatilag ez ezért egy természeti
törvény mert hogyha magára hagysz egy
rendszert akkor akkor ez a természetes
így áll be le merem fogadni hogyha most
a városokat nézzük akkor a városok
forgalma is így áll be hogy hogy ha
tegyük fel most hány városban vagytok
ött városban hát igen most
ha most vanr hat igazából hat hogy el
tudom képzelni hogy a hat városból egybe
annyi forgalom van vagy kettőben mint az
összes többibe ez ez jól tippelemebe
vagy eléggé jól kiegyenlítődik és a
másik kérdés pedig az hogy a a partnerek
között is hogy egy szűk kisebbsége a
partnereknek akkora hozammal rendelkezik
mint az összes többi partner ühüm ez az
utóbbi ez ez közelebb áll a a valósághoz
tehát itt itt azért működik a paratóelv
tényleg megvannak azok a partnerek
akiktől a rendelések nagy hányada
érkezik üüm és a tebbi partnktől pedig
gyakorlatilag van tehát van olyan város
ahol mondjuk három partnertől érkezik
annyi rendelés az összes többitől és sőt
ennek megvan a matematikai szabálya is
tehát gyak alatt ahány partnered van
tehát most van 200 partner az 14 a gyak
alatt 214 körül lehet valahogy úgy
tippelnék hogy 14 partnernek annyi a
hozama mint az összes többinek ez ez
beletalált-e nem ép 14 de nyilván nem
tehát
jobban kezdelett a 14-hez mint a 100-hoz
mondjuk ühüm
tehát itt például a városok tekintetében
sokkal kiegyenlítőbb sokkal
kiegyenlítettebb a dolog tehát a azt
mondhatom hogy csík és udvarhely azért
elég fejfejvett mozognak ühüm
és nagyon szépen fejlődött például
udvarhely annak ellenére hogy később
indult el később léptünk a piacra
nagyon dinamikusan fejlődött hát
gyakorlat halt még mindig kettő körül
van úgyhogy tehát hogy csík és udvar
helyett vesszük a többi négynek a a
hozama igen ugyanúgy tehát ha arányaiba
nézzük ugye gyergny mondjuk egy kisebb
város kétszer kisebb mint csík
arányaibaan gyakorlatilag ott ott ott
helyezkedik el mondjuk mint csíkés
udvarhá nyilván számokban mondjuk fele
felét hozza de arányaiban azért
[Zene]
hogyha lakosságarányosan nézzük akkor
akkor ott nagyjából ez a piacfelvevő erő
ez körülbelül itt h arányosab piac
magával a lakossággal de viszont a
lakosság is a parat evet követi úgyhogy
gyanítom hogy ha eléggé terjeszkedtek
akkor tehát tegyük fel most négy-öt év
múlva ülünk lebeszélgetni akkor azt
hiszem hogy a paretto fz közelíteni fog
jobban a a a városokban levő hozam is
igen valószínű tehát valószínűleg hogyha
már nem hat városról hanem 30 városról
beszélnénk akkor más lenne más lenne a
gyerekfekvés amúgy látsz-e esély például
hogy bukarestbe terjeszkedjetek tehát el
el tud-e jutni oda há van-e benne akkora
potenciál hogy a itt a nagy városokat
meghódítsátok
összességben nem is szeretnénk nagy
városokba tergeszkedni inkább az a
víziónk hogy a vidéki városokat célozzuk
meg és
azok azért mert a mi rendszerünk inkább
erre lett kitalálva akarva
akaratlanul ezekbe a 30-40000es
városokba indultunk el és akarvakaratlan
rendszert erre építettük fel és így tud
megmaradni egyébként a személyesség is
az hogy az hogy személyesen tudunk a
partnereinkkel és hogyha van probléma
beszélgetni
személyesen tudunk a klienseknek is a
problémáit megoldani
és azt gondolom hogy egy nagy város
persze azért eléggé elérhetetlen lenne
úgyhogy a vidéki városokat céloz meg
például magyarországon van a
falatos.hu és pont valakivel
beszélgettem a tegnap és ő mondta hogy
ismeré a srácokat akik alapították nekik
is az volt a céljuk ők miskolcó indultak
hogy a vidéki városokba tergeszkedjenek
mert akkor már budapesten nagyon jelen
volt a futpanda meg talán volt is volt
már az kicsit hüén hangzott de igen
és a vidéki városokat kezdték megcélozni
és így tudtak amúgy nagyra nőni tehát í
így az ember ha ránéz magyarországra
akkor azt látja hogy van foodóra most
már is volt de közben mellette van egy
csomó vidéki város ahol ahol nagyon erős
mjuk a falatos.hu és nagyjából ez lenne
a célunk nekünk is hogy ezekbe a vidéki
városokba terjeszkedni és megerősedni
nagyvárosokba olyan olyan teménytelen
marketing büdzsére lenne szükség ami
hogy veszteségesek lennétek tehát pont
pont abba a cipőbe lépnénk bele talán
ami mútik hogy folyamatos
tőkeinjekció folyamatos folyamatos
hatalmas marketing költségek értékesítés
költségek és add ugye ez addig működik
amíg van van ahonnan befektetni vagy van
aki befektessen de attól a pillanattól
valahol csak meg
kell így és valahol csak meg kell
forduljon mert ha valahol nem fordul meg
akkor akkor egy idő után nyilván senki
nem fog tehát mindenkinek mi a célja az
hogy egy az egy profitábilis és jól
működő céget építsen és hiába vannak itt
van egy érdekes elv kíváncsi vagyak a
véleményedre ezel ez egy félkéz gondolat
tehát még én is én is így emézgetem
magamban
hogy valami van a személyes kapcsolatban
valami történt a világunkban ami talán a
2020-as évek körül tehát a covid
lehetett egy ilyen váltás amikor lassan
rá kellett jöjjünk arra hogy a személyes
kapcsolatok fontosak ez érvényes sok
szinten tehát hogy érvényes arra is hogy
hogy a programozók elkezdtek home
office-ba dolgozni de most most van egy
visszavándorlás megint a a az irodákban
mert vágyunk arra hogy személyes
kapcsolataink legyenek de te is most az
ez előbb megemlítetted hogy az egyik
titka az a személyes kapcsolat nemrég
beszélgettem vincellér árpáddal aki a
weckernek az alapítója és pont ő is a
közösségről beszélt és a személyes
kapcsolatokról és pont talán ez is
hiányzik a multiknál hogy akkorák hogy
nem tudnak már személyes kapcsolatot
vagy lehet hogy a nem is tudom hogy ez
ez lehet-e valaki akkora hogy képtelen
legyen személyes kapcsolatokat ápolni
mert tudom képzelni hogyha a víziójukban
az lenne hogy személyes kapcsolatot
ápoljanak akkor talán tudnának tenni
valamit annak érdekében hogy hogy
személyesebb legyen egy egy globo
például de van ebben valami bölcsesség
tehát hogy talán ezt ezt lehet
általánosítani is hogy akármilyen piacon
is dolgozol a személyes kapcsolat az egy
ez egy nem elhanyagolható plusz érték
amit egy hozzáadott érték amit a amit be
bevezethetsz a cégedhez nem neked mi a
véleményed erről én is így gondolom és
nem nem tudom hogy a covid hozta-e az
egészet ez a 2020-as év
igazából mi akkor indultunk úgyhogy
nincs nagyon összehasonlítási alapon
hogy azelőtt hogy történtek volna a
dolgok meg azután de azt hiszem hogy
kiéleszte a covid nem nem nem az okozója
hanem inkább csak a igen taln felszzi
elhozta az hogy az hogy mennyire fontos
és akkor amikor nyilván viszonylag jó
buli volt hogy márciustól júniusig
otthon ültünk én is tudtam csomót
kertészkedni tehát felüdülés volt de
mégis mégis az az hogy online dolgoztunk
és nem volt meg ez a kötődés ez ez azért
sok sok mindent befolyásolt és pont ez a
bizalom és az a személyes kötődés az ami
ami szerintem
eljuttat akár üzleti kapcsolatokat is
olyan szintre hogy hogy hogy hogy már a
mondjuk a partnered ne gondolkozzon azon
hogy csatlakozik egy egy multihoz mert
nincs értelme egyrészt látja hogy nem
igazán ég meg üzletileg meg nem lesz nem
lesz különösebb aannak de másrészt
megvan ez a lojalitás hogy hogy nekem is
vannak tényleg olyan üzletek vagy olyan
márkák amihez annyira lojális vagyok
hogyha drágább is de tudom hogy az a
minőséget adja és akkor inkább az fogom
megvásárolni és pont azért mert
megvannak ezek a személyes kapcsolatok
és mi azzal azt is próbáljuk egyébként a
hammal pont ezt a közösség közösségi
építést is igyekszünk előtéb helyezni
hogy hogy és azt nem nem feltétlen ss
tehát nem nem egy marketing fog
hanem sokszor sokszor
belemegyünk ilyen kampányokba vagy
tervezünk ilyen kampányokat hogy volt
ilyen véradásos kampányunk volt volt
ilyen gyereknapi kampány hogy hogy
gyűjtötünk és a tényleg nem tehetős tehá
gyakorlatilag a szegény sorssú
gyerekeknek szállítottunk ki pizzát vagy
adtunk kuponokat hogy tudják beváltani
pizzára
mert nem t tehát minden nap ők nem
tudnak tehát lehet lehet egy egy egy
középosztálybeli gyereknek ez normális
hogy három naponta pizzát eszik de nekik
lehet hogy egy évben se adatik meg és
akkor ezeket a dolgokat így picit ezeket
a a társadalmi problémákba és egy picit
belenyúlni kicsit segíteni ezeken vagy
vagy hozzáadni valamit próbálunk
visszaadni nyilván szervezünk
nyereményjátékokat is ahol lehet nyerni
most legutóbb volt egy nyereményjátékunk
nyaralást lehetett nyerni meg meg
meg
hasonlókat meg eszközöket de de
fontosnak tartjuk azt hogy ezt a ezt a
közösséget ezt a egyenőre ugye a
székelyföldi
közösségnek visszaadjunk mertát azért
sokat kaptunk nyilván az emberek nélkül
mi se lennénk ott mi se lennénk ott ahol
vagyunk és fontos az és talán az a
legnehezebb hogy ezt a fókuszt
megtartani a növekedés mellett tehát van
egy van egy növekedés van egy
tergeszkedés és hogy attól a fókuszt
tart tarts rajta hogy ez nem magától
értetőő nem természetes hanem ha nem
ápolod ezeket a kapcsolatokat az
emberekkel hiába van mondjuk 50000
felhasználód és nyilván 50000 embk nem
tudsz mondjuk felhívni vagy elhívni
kávézni vagy hasonló most az 50zt azért
mondod meg annyinál tartatok igen most
már súroljuk az zet igen igen az szép
igen nyilvánnek a az aktív az aktív
rendelői réteg ez nem 500 de hogy hogy
marr annyir hisk az menny az aktív
gondolom 2-3000 körül lehet így most
érzi most pontosan nem tudom megmondani
de igen igen igen az a k3 4000 k nyilván
az attól függ hogy honnan nézzük hogy
napiendelő vagy heti vagy havi vagy
két-három naponta ez ez ot sok mindentől
függ én például heti rendelő vagyok
tehát attól függetlenül van van olyan
két hét hogy minden nap rendelek de van
olyan két hét hogy nem rendelek
egyáltalán ühüm
de hát igen egy olyan két-három naponta
átlagba azért egy egy egy ebédet azért
megeszek a hamró a a másik minta ami ami
újra és újra feljön bennem az az hogy
vajon külföldön éri megélni vagy haza
megéri költözni tehát hogy ezt ezt most
szépen ki is bontottad hogy itthon nem
volt piaca ennek az egésznek most
dánielba könnyebb létrehozni egy ilyent
vagy itt a kicsi otthonunkba és
egyértelműen látszik hogy végtelen
lehetőség van körülöttünk amit ez sincs
és az sincs gyakorlatilag elégedetlen
éggel tölthet el de valójában másképp is
lehet nézni a dolgokat mégpedig az hogy
itt a lehetőség hogy hozzunk valami újat
és kiépítsünk valamit ahogy mondtad maga
a a szállítás sem volt még kiépítve a
kultúra sem volt kiépítve az emberek
veled együtt tanulták meg hogy hogy
mennyivel egyszerűbb rendelni egy ételt
és néha tényleg szükséges az hogy ha
valamit ünnepelni akarsz és nincs időd
főzni akkor akkor gyorsan rendelsz
valamit és ott van a terített asztal
előtted úgyhogy úgyhogy azt hiszem hogy
akkor te is egyetértesz les ezzel hogy
meg hazaköltözni nyilván benne volt az
haz költöztetek de de én azt látom hogy
tele van lehetőségekkel a környezetünk
igen igen én egyébként gyakorlatilag a a
neveltetésemől fakadóan is mindig az
volt az én hozzáállásom meg álláspontom
hogy csak lehet itthon is nem nem az van
hogy hogy nincsenek lehetőségek nyilván
sokkal egyszerűbb danelba kítóként is
egy nagyon jó életszímalat el tudsz érni
el tudsz venni három havonta nyaralni
valenciával vagy akármi de az a kérdés
hogy mi a cél tehát azt gondolom hogy
itthon is egy becsületes jó életszíonat
el lehet érni akkor hogyha tényleg az
ember ne az energiáit nem arra pazarolja
hogy hogy hú nem lehet itthonos tényleg
milyen nehéz de amúgy van v egy hazugság
tehát hogy hogy külföldön sem könnyebb
valójább nem kön egyáltalán n és
abszolút kliséden nins kóbászból a
kerítés tehát én is dánielba éjszaka
újságot voltam felkeltem éjjel -kor
f:30-kor elmentem kijogtam az újságot
hazamentem letusoltam mentem egyetemre h
és ilyen négy-5t órákat aludtam és volt
egy szabadnapom egy héten úgyhogy azt
próbáltam
íy elkezdtem még a társaságélet is élni
hogyha lehetett mellette ú má magyarokat
ismertél dánielb igen akar akaratlan
azért az ember így í így
vagy akár székelyeket is húz húz a húz a
saját
saját nem akarom csúnyán kifejezni de
hogy a azok az emberek felé akik akik
azért hasonlóan gondolkodnak és
mehettünk meg és mkettünk meg olyan
magyarokkal vagy itthoni személyekkel is
akik akiket azát nem ismertünk üüm cső
mikkel foglalkoztak kén nagyrészt
ugyanez a mondjuk ilyen újságot ttam ott
a cégnél is egyébként 80 sz-a volt román
10%-a volt dély magyar és 10%-a volt
litván lengyel körülbelül ez volt sokal
voltam hogy 40-50 ember dolgozott ennél
a ebbe a városba
úgyhogy
fú mi is volt a kérdés igen hogy más
magyarokat ismerté éső mikkel
foglalkkooz igen ott ismertünk meg de
például mellette takarítottunk
ilyen vakációs
házakba meg hotelekbe és gyakorlatilag
ilyen nyilván mivel ebbe dolgoztunk ebbe
ismer ismertünk meg több magyart de
nagyjából ebbe ebbe a ebbe dolgoztak ők
is
takarítás az ilyen az olyan munkák
amiket már a dánok nem végeztek el
mert nem akartak vagy nem volt szükség
volt egy dán munkatársam is egyébként
aki egyébként azért csinálta azt mondta
mert ő szereti el a csendbe
motorozgatni és igazából ez volt neki a
cíve amúgy nem olyan nem volt olyan nagy
élmény mert azért dániel ismer hát
ismeres arra hogy nagyon sokat esik ugye
főleg így ősztől tavaszig és az első
hónapban hát szerintem egy becsáet is
tüő gyulladást összeszedtem mert mind
meg torok gyulladás mert hangom se volt
már és folyamatosan mehett az eső de
megvolt eg cél megvolt az hogy van ennek
egy egy hosszút távú kifutása és másképp
akkor szedhegyük a sátó fankats mehetünk
haza de akkor nem ez volt a cél hanem
hogy elvégezni ezt a ezt a mesterit
aztán meg aztán meg úgy szépen
felépíteni a dolgokat akkor még nem
tudtuk de de hogy megvolt ez a ez a
hazaköltözésnek a célja és bár ismertünk
meg ott magyarokat de sokan amúgy haza
is költöztek közülük vannak akik nem és
egyébként volt olyan volt olyan
ismeretségünk kint aki azt mondta hogy é
só többet haz nem költöz nem is
költözött haza nyilván valami tüske
benne maradt és azt mondta hogy ő
szerintem ilyen ilyen csal ádi történet
lehetett a hattékbe de azért mindenkiben
benne volt ez a az a vágyódás hm ez
egészen elképesztő azért mert emlékszem
amikor jordan peterson által megértettem
a a bibliából az ószövetségből azt a
történetet amikor noé a az özönvíz után
letelepszik és elkezd szőlőt termeszteni
és akkor a szőlőnek a a borából
megrészegedik és kifekszik a sátrába és
kilátszik a szemérme és akkor jön az
egyik fia és gyakorlatilag megszégyeníti
kikacagja megy a másik két testvéréhez
és elmondja hogy mi történt a másik két
testvére pedig jön és alázatosan háttal
fordulva betakarja noét egy nagyon
furcsa történet ja igen és akkor noé a
végén amikor ezt megtudja akkor akkor
kiátkozza a fiát és az az úgy átkozza ki
hogy mostantól kezdve szolgálja leszel
minden népnek rettenetesen furcsa
történet és a cinizmust az emberbe
felhozza az ilyen ateista vonalát hogy
ennél őrültebb történetet és még
komolyan is vegyük ez ez és peterson
által értettem meg hogy nem nem nem itt
valójában mélyen ez az az örök történet
amit folyamatosan élünk vagyis az van
hogy van egy hagyaték egy atyai hagyaték
amit gyakorlatilag erdély is a múltunk a
vérrel
verejtékkel
megszerzett vagyon vagy tudás amit
kapunk a kezünkbe és a kérdés hogy mit
csinálunk ezzel a a vérrel verejtékkel
megszerzett vagyonnal mert valójában
kilátszik a szemérme minden egyes dolog
amit kaptunk az valahol korrupt is tehát
látszik a a románia korrupt erdély
korrupt a politikusok a a a politikai
rendszerek a tanügy a minden akárhova
nézünk az egyház mindenhol problémákat
látunk és akkor kérdés hogy mit kezdünk
ezzel mert kilóg a szemérme és az egyik
attitűd az hogy hogy kikacagjuk és azt
mondjuk hogy hát itt őült aki itt marad
erdélybe és elmegyünk külföldre mert azt
mondjuk hogy hogy it nincs nincs értelme
maradni mert itt mindenki korrupt és és
nem lehet boldogulni de viszont a az
atyai átok rajta az hogy szolga leszel
és ez amikor megértettem hogy te jó m
pont ez történik kimegyünk külföldre és
újságot fogunk kihordani és az amit
elmeséltél hogy gyakorlatilag mindenki
valamilyen szolgamunkát végzett
külföldön versusz hogyha hazajössz és
alázatosan betakarod az atyai szemérmet
ami kilóg és elkezded javítgatni a
dolgokat mert valójában pont ezt
csináltad elkezdted építeni ezt a hammot
és egyszer több komplex problémával
kezdtél foglalkozni mert itt van maga az
ételkiszállítási kérdés egy kulturális
kérdés és egy tehát rengeteg komplex
dolgot kellett valahogy megoldjál és
erről is akarok mindjárt egy kicsit
beszélni de pont ez történt hogy azáltal
hogy alázatosan háttal fordulva az atyai
szemérmet betakarod ezáltal tudod
úgymond egy magasabb szintre emelni és
majd te is ezt tovább fogod adni ezt az
atyai hagyatékot nekem egészen
elképesztő hogy hogy gyakorlatilag te a
bőrödön tapasztaltad a ennek a ennek az
archetipikus alapelvnek a a működését
igen ez egy nagyon nagyon pontos
hasonlat volt nem is hallottam még ezt
vr nem is volt ahol
igen igen és igaz ából pontosan az van
hogy hogyha lefordítjuk ezt kimegy
kimész az ember kimegy az ember
külföldre dolgozik még akkor is hogyha
mondjuk meg tud lépni néhány lépcsőfokot
de mindig meglesz az a az a az a fal én
azt éreztem hogy van az a fal hogy te ú
úgy se leszel te dan tehát hogy soha nem
leszel soha nem fognak úgy kezelni
nagyon barácsal csak tényleg
elképesztően szimpatikus népadan de de
mindig van az az a fal és és és ott
megállsz és ott ott nem nem tudsz az
azon már nem ó az nagyon magas az a fal
tehát az ahogy azt megm az az nem tudom
hogy le lehet hogy pár évtizededbe kerül
hogy felkerülj oda ahova a az az alap a
ezt éreztem én is amúgy brüsszelben hogy
igen hogy kedvesek de van egy távolság
van egy távolság köztem és köztük és
igen ugyanez és valószínűen hogyha
valaki hozzánk jönne így ugyanez
ugyanezt érezni mert nem tudjuk m a
magunk közé valónak tekinteni akarva
akaratlan lehetünk nyilván megvan a
híres székely vendégfogadás meg ez a
hozzáállás de akarra akaratlan nem tehát
akárhova mész idegenként nem leszel ott
otthon és azt gondolom hogy az egy
teljesen normális mégis csak sok minden
kötössz minket nát nem is vesszük észre
mennyi minden kötössz minket de pontosan
de valakivel leülsz beszélgetni és érzed
hogy ez valahonnan székelyföldről
származhat mert mert hasonlóak vagyunk
vagy
ennek nagyon örrvendek e ez nagyon
nagyon tetszett egy kicsit még
beszélgetnék magáról a a
cégkultúrátokról ugyanis tudom hogy
neked
nagyon a szíveden van hogy egy céges
környezet ne a profitról szóljon vagy ne
csak a profit a profit az egy kellék így
elmondtad hogy ha nincs profit akkor
nincs játék tehát nem lehet iterálni a
játékot hosszú távon de nem lehet a cél
úgyhogy egy kicsit beszélgetnél-e a
célról hogy neked mi a célod és hogy
egyáltalán ez a a az emberi oldala amit
annyit annyiszor felhoztál hogy ez ez ez
miért fontos
számodra a nekünk ami amikor indítottuk
a céget akkor alapvetően az volt a
célunk hogy hogy a meg is volt
fogalmazva a vízió hogy a székelyföldi
vállalkozóknak
segíteni és biztosítani egy egy online
láthatóságot akkor még ez volt a cél
ugye hammal azért ez már másképp néz ki
azért elég közel van mert ahogy mondtad
a covid alatt jó pár cég pont emiatt
tudott fennmaradni tehát a láthatóságát
segítettétek és egy egy szűk szegmensnek
a láthatóságát abszolút felemelted majd
erről is kérdeznék még valamit de akkor
nem nem vágok a szavadba ebbe én nem is
gondoltam bele egyébként hogy ez a vízió
mennyire húzhatóra a hamra de így most
jó hogy említetted
nem tudom hogy
szerintem valahonnan belülről egyrészt
valahonnan belülről mérről
gyökereztethető az hogy hogy mi
próbáljuk ezt a cégkultúrá
meg a piacon való
úgymond viselkedésünket tehát a brend
általi viselkedésünket
az hatgja át hogy hogy tényleg fontosak
az emberek fontos a közösség és fontosak
a személyes kapcsolatok ez nyilván
tudatos is tehát hogy van egy tudatosság
benne de az hogy hogy hogy honnan jön a
gyökere mert hogyha mondjuk egy
felszínes cselekvés lenne vagy egy ilyen
pótcselekvés hogy na most azért
próbáljuk ezt mutatni hogy rendelenek
meg jól hangzik meg legyen egy egy jó
kis
piarértéke akkor az nem nem lehet hosszú
hosszútávon fenntartani ühüm és inkább
csak az hogy eddig is ott volt ez a
gyökér csak most már verbálisan meg
tudod fogalmazni és tudatosan tudsz róla
hogy hogy ott van az a gyökér ami amúgy
is ott van így van így van és és tud
tudattalanul vagy tudatosan úgy
választottuk ki az embereket is a a
cégbe hogy nekik is az fontos legyen és
fontos legyen az hogy nyilván a profit
egy nagyon fontos dolog mert anélkül
nincs meg ez a meg ez a folytonosság és
nem tud tényleg nem tudsz arra
fókuszálni hogy a fejlődés meg az
emberek meg a cég meg a fejlesztés és
ami a lényeg tehát nem tudsz arra
fókuszálni
de de de emögött sokkal fontosabb az
hogyha már megvan ez a ez az eszköz a
kezedben a profit akkor sokkal fontosabb
az hogy mit tudsz hogy tudsz építkezni
ebből és azokat az embereket meg tudtuk
találni mert ugye azért eléggé elszótan
vagyunk jelen mindenhol viszont minden
városban vagy minden területen
megtaláltuk azokat az embereket akik
akiknek fontos az hogy hogy hogy a
személyes kapcsolattartás jelen legyen
hogy a közösség közösségnek
visszaadjanak még és még sokszor akkor
is hogyha ez egy picit fáj a cégnek hogy
mondjuk kompenzálni kell valamit nem ami
hibán volt eszem fel mondjuk az étterem
egyet hibázik és és akkor emiatt egy nem
tudom egy 200 les rendelés elúszik és
akkor ezt mi kompenzáljuk de de fontos
az hogy az emberek lass s hogy ezt mi
tényleg komolyan gondoljuk és ez
belülről jön tehát nem az van hogy hogy
amikor már van egy szint és afölött már
úgy ki kibújik a szeg a zsákból hogy hát
ez csak egy ilyen illúzió akar lenni
tulajdonképpen úgyhogy val valahogy így
ez egy ilyen belső belső késztetés talán
ez nekem valószínű mondom jön a ilyen
lehet hogy a genetikában is benne van
meg belülről is jön de ugyanúgy szabinak
is ez a beállítottság a céktarsomnak
akivel legtöbb döntést hozzuk hogy hogy
hogy azért kell tehát ez ez egy
nagyon-nagyon fontos szempont az egyik
legfontosabb szempont hog tehát a
világképeteket átvette a cég is és és
éli gyakorlatilag így van ez egy ez egy
tényleg egy egy nagyon érdekes dolog és
az a szépebből ebben hogy hogy ez
profitábilissá teszi a céget tehát hogy
ez nem csak egy alapelv ami ami izgalmas
és jól hangzik de a biznisvilág másképp
működik hanem pont emiatt működik a
biznisvilágban jól a égetek mert mert
ezt az alapelvet él tehát ez egy dupla
nyereség valójában mert egy gondolom
hogy amikor lefekszel akkor ez egy öröm
hogy hogy a mai napot is úgy tudtuk
zárni hogy az embert választottuk és nem
a profitot és ráadásul még profitábilis
a cégem miatt is úgyhogy ez ez és akkor
ez hogyan jelenik meg a cégkultúrába
tehát hogy te direkt be a kliensekkel
gondolom nem beszélsz vagy a a
partnerekkel most már vagy gondolom hogy
most már annyira azért naggyá vált
minden hogy hogy megvannak a szerepkörök
és neked nem feltétlenül a sz az a
direkt a partnkkel besél gondolom hogy
ritkán nyilván megtörténik amikor
szükséges de neked talán mint ahogyha a
missziód inkább a csapatod lenne hogy a
csapaton belül a kohézió a bizalom a
lehetőlemagasabb legyen és a csapatnak a
feladata az hogy viszont a hámot
működtesse így van így van nem mondom
hogy nem beszélek még most is van hogy
valahonnan a telefonszámom csak a
legelején az volt hogy a a mivel mindent
mi csináltunk tehát sokszor mi
szállítottuk az ételt és amikor
elindítottuk a száítás szolgálatot
sokszó kocsib ütem fel voltak oszva a
műszakok és én is szállítottam néha né
most is azért biciklire ülök és főleg
azért hog kicsit lassa éni tehát ne az
legyen hogy a futárok így így fel kell
nézzenek hogy na vajon akkor milyen
milyen rossz időben dolgozni és akkor
nézzük hogy lajs ott ül a meleg irodalba
de nem pont az az a cél hogy hogy hogy
ezzel ezzel egyrészt a csapatot is
jobban összehozzuk és lássam hogy hogy
mik a problémák mik lehet javítani még
tényleg itt ott milyen problémák
merülnek fel amin amin amin tényleg
dolgozni kell
úgyhogy néha azért beszélek néha
megtalálnak a partnerek is ami nem
probléma visszahívom én ha nem tudok
beszélni vagy beszélünk de most már le
vannak tehát eljutottunk hálistennek a
delegálásnak arra a szintjére hogy most
már nem csináljuk ezeket a
mikromenedzseri feladatokat és én is én
is
azért sok sok nagy elhatá ás kellett
ahhoz hogy ezeket le tudjam osztani pont
talán a legutóbb beszéltünk arról hogy a
delegálásban te mondtad azt hiszem azt a
80%-os számot hogy akkor
igen hogy az az egy szabály hogy 80%-kal
ha el tudja végezni valaki a te
feladatodat vagy azt a feladatot akkor
le kell azt delegálni és ez a felismerés
nehéz hogy sokszor úgy gondoltam én is
hogy j én tudok meg tudom oldani jobban
tényleg sokszor így is volt de hogy
hogyha szinte olyan jól meg tudja oldani
a kolléga akkor miért ne adjam le mert
tulajdonképpen nem veszítek én sokkal
több energiát nyerek azzel ezzel mint
amennyit mondjuk veszitek hogyha egy
picivel pvel vassabban vagy gyengébben
oldja meg itt főleg főleg a gyósasa
igazából itt a lényeg és és ráadásul
növekszik ő is tehát legközelebb 82%-ra
és 85 í így lassan megsinál így van és a
felelősség azért mégis csak ugye az
embereknek pont az hogy kell a
felelősség ahhoz hogy tudjon kicsit
ebből a komfortzónábó kilépjen és tudjon
tudjon fejlődni és akor meg meg ez
valahol bó is hogy azt látom hogy te ezt
meg tudod tenni úgyhogy gyakorlatilag
hogy megtiszteled a munkatársadat azzal
hogy egy picivel nagyobb felelősséget
adsz neki mint amit úgy látod hogy
megbír vagy am pontosan pontosan és
annak tehát nyilván most már sokat nem
kommunikálok így még megtalálnak néha
felínak egy rendelésel kapcsolatban
nézem honnan van meg a telefonszáam de
azt is lekzelem átadom megmondom hogy ne
kerestek ezt tá é sem mi a helyzet
vagy kimaradt valami bármi
de igen tehát nagyrészt most már
most már főleg adminiszatív feladatokat
látok el a cégbe és az ilyen stratégiai
döntéseket hozom meg mert most már
tényleg minden területnek megvan az a
felelőse az a felelőse ami ami amit úgy
el tud végezni tehát az a személy el
tudja úgy végezni ahogy ahogy el kell
végezni
és nagyon sok olyan kolléga van vagy van
olyan aki aki mondjom hogy szülésén van
de hogy akár aki pályakezdőként kezdte
nálunk és nagyon nagyon tehát láthatóan
nagyon sokat fejlődött tehát olyan
szinten hogy lehet hogy ezt mondjuk egy
multinal nem kapta volna meg mert nem
kapta volna meg ezeket a felelősségi
köröket és nem tudott volna ilyen
gyorsan ilyen ütembbe fejlődni tehát ez
is egy másik nagy tanulság hogy hogy egy
érdemes egy kisebb cégnél kezdeni
mármint hogy nem elvetendő gondolat az
hogy egy kisebb cégnél kezdjük mert a
multi nem minden szempontból jobb én is
emlékszem egy multinál kezdtem el
dolgozni és most utólag látva a
fizetésem nagyon jó volt de utólag látva
talán jobb lett volna hogyha egy kisebb
cégnél kezdek megvolt nyilván ennek is a
pozitív hozadéka de de sok mindentől
megmentett a a egy egy múltis környezet
nem kellett egy csomó minden apró
részlettel foglalkozzak és éveken
keresztül egy projekten dolgoztam ami
mégis csak másabb mint hogyha két-három
havonta más-más technológia hiába kezdek
dolgozni igen és nincs is meg a nincs
meg a lehetőség meg egy egy multicégnél
nincs tényleg nincs meg az a lehetőség
amik ahol több százan dolgoznak hogy
mindenkivel hacsak nincs erre
nagyon-nagyon erős akarat hogy
mindenkivel legyen meg ez a ez a
személyes kötődés és legyen meg ez a az
utánkövetés hogy milyen felelősségeket
kapott meg az ő fejlődésének a követése
hogy na most már lehet talán többet
terhelni azért egy kis cégnél ez jobban
követhető és jobban látható könnyebben
leülsz és beszélgetsz egyet és akkor
látod hogy könnyebben kiszűred a
problémákat is ilyen szempontból igen
igen fájdalmasabbak a hibák egy kis
cégnél tehát hogy ami és és emiatt oda
kell figyelni még egy nagy cégnél
elelbújhat egy ember a felelőség aló ab
itt még lenne egy kérdésem van-e valaki
aki az adott területen akár nem csak
80%-ra hanem 110-re megoldja tehát hogy
jobbá vált mint te az az adott területen
igen
pont
voltam egy képzésen tavaly balogpetya
képzésen ugye magyarországon egy ilyen
hát cápa onnan ismerhetik a legtöbben és
ő mesélte el a saját történetét hogy
ugye programozó és és tényleg a legjobb
programozó volt a saját cégében amikor
céget csinált de amikor már egyre
növekedett akkor akkor kellett
válasszalom hogy itt most programozni
akar vagy céget vezetni
és és pont pont amikor elmondta hogy
tulajdonképpen a a mikor a cégvezetés
választotta akkor látta meg hogy a
vállalkozás az az egy tehát a vállalkozó
az egy szokma tehát a vállalkozás az egy
céget vezetni az egy külön szakma az nem
csak annyit jelent hogy hogy na egy
céget é aztán ott elutalgatod a pénzeket
és kicsit ezt felveszed az embereket és
így működik automatikusan hanem minden
területben bele kell lassal egy kicsit
mindenhez hozá én itt közben
jegegyzeteltem hogy mennyi mindenhez
kellett értsé ott kezdődött a
piackutatása hogy végig kellett mondjuk
még mondhatnánk azt hogy a piaackutatás
még valahol a a ezt tanultad tehát hogy
a marketingen a de ott van maga a sales
része tehát hogy hogy azt viszont nem
tanultad van egy marketing része van egy
technológiai része van egy emberi része
amelyik egy diplomáciával foglal tehát
nagyon komplex emberekkel dolgozni és
erről ma egy kicsit beszélnénk utána
hogy milyen komplexitása van tehát hog
ennyi minden mellett amit felépítettél
az emberekkel mennyire nehéz külön
dolgozni de ott van a a az hogy egy
szállítási piacot kellett kiépítsetek
ami azelőtt nem vol volt és és zéróról
kitalálni ezt az egészet
szóval hihetetlenül színes az a paletta
ami minimum kellett ahhoz hogy működjön
tehát bármelyik hiányzik ez az egész
megomlik ez az egész rendszer
igen igen és
hát igen ugye marketinget végeztem
alpeten tehát ilyen a piaackutatás meg a
marketing része az az úgy rendben
volt a technológia része része azért
volt rendben mert szabia cégtarsam ő ő
egy nagyon nagy tapasztalattal
rendelkező fejlesztő tát ilyen
szempontból ezek ezek a területei a
cégnek jól működtek mag az elején de nem
volt césszesünk nyilván nem is volt
pénzünk célszesre volt egy-két ismerős
akik akikkel megbeszéltük hogy hogy na
akkor hozzál be ittermeket és kapsz
jutalékot és próbáltuk ezt valahogy
pörgetni de nem volt szészesünk szóval
mentünk leültünk targyoltunk kijöttünk
vagy volt szerződés vagy nem de akkor
újra próbálkoztunk és és ott is egy
csomó tapasztalatot szereztünk
csomó technikát nyilván olvasgattam is
volna hogy ezt hogy kéne csinálni de de
akkor is arra jöttem rá hogy itt a
legfontosabb a szézb is az hogy hogy
egyrészt hogy jó legyen a terméked az
egyértelmű és legyen egy jó ajánlatod de
legyél őszintés akkor a bizalom is
kialakul és én én azt mondtam amikor
leültem hogy ne jösztök első nap 100
rendelésetek lesz azt mondtam hogy még
mi se tudjuk ez egy új piac de biztos
vagyok benne hogy hogy hosszút távon ez
egy nagyon nagyon kifizetődő történet
lesz és így is lett mert látszottak a
tendenciák de emellett igen ami az egyik
legnagyobb kihívás volt az az a
logisztika és a
szállítási szolgáltatásnak a kiépítése
ugye hozzá kellett rendelni a
technológiai egészt is azóta kevésbé
nagyobb nagy kihívás de az a nagyobb
kihívás hogy ezt
megszervezni kialakítani több városba
úgyhogy úgyhogy sok sok mindenhez hozzá
kellett sok területhez és pontosan azt
hiszem hogy itt itt
itt rejlik a a kulcsa egy jó tehát nem
tudom jó vállalkozó vagyok-e de hogy
hogy itt kell itt kell észrevegye az
ember hogy hogy most már tényleg vagy
céget akar vezetni vagy mondjuk a saját
szakmájáb fejlődni mert a kettő nem megy
együtt és hogyha céget akarsz vezetni
akkor kezdél hozzányúlni területekhez
bele kell látni a dolgokba és igen
vannak tehát most már azt mondom hogy
nagyon sokan a cégből
10010%-ban csinálják azt amit én mondjuk
100-baan tudnám csinálni mert ugye az az
ő területük azzal foglalkoznak és
nyilván attól független hogy én
belelátok de gyakorlatilag azon kívül
hogy tárgyalásokra járok megbeszélések
mondjuk még a pénzügyekkel én
foglalkozom meg az adminisztrációval de
ezen kívül én ezekbe a területekben csak
így felületesen vagyok benne mikor kell
egy kicsit jobban mondjuk a marketingre
rzében vagy a a szész részében
összefogjuk a dolgokat
tatykakapcsolatot de összességében
mindenhez is kell egy picit érteni és
pit hozzányúlni és ha felismeri ezt az
ember úgy gondolom ez volt az egyik
legfontosabb felismerés nekem is hogy ne
akarjak mindent mindenkinél jobban
megcsinálni hanem hanem a felelősséget
osszam ki és bízom abb hogy azok az
emberek akiket kiválasztottunk azok jó
emberek és képesek arra hogy ezeket
megoldjak üm ez nagyon szép így a
beszélgetésor korán úgy kezd kezdett
kirajzolódni a fejemen hogy mi az ami a
te erősséged mi az ami a te
gyengeséged azt szokták mondani hogy a
az erősség ha le kell érni három dolgot
erősségnek akkor az az nagyon nehezen
megs ha gyengeségnek nagyon nagyon
könnyen
de igen tehát az egyik gyengeségem talán
az amben úgy gondolom már sokat
fejlődtem az az hogy
hogy konfliktuső vagyok tehát nem nem
yek olyan könnyen bele konfliktusokba és
és különböző olyan feszültebb
helyzetekbe amik amik tényleg részemről
egy egy egy kényelmetlen szituációt
alakítanának ki hanem inkább kikerülm s
akkor valahogy valahogy ezt megoldjuk de
de ebben is sokat fejlődtem még mindig
kell viszont viszont megtanultam azt
hogy hogy van egy van egy probléma vagy
van egy van egy cél
vagy bármi és hogyha az azzal jár vagy
annak az elérése vagy annak a megoldása
azzal jár hogy felvállaljunk egy egy
nézeteltérést egy konfliktust akkor azt
fel kell vállalni mert hogyha a
szőnyagalá söpörjük akkor az csak nőni
fog ugye és megbotlunk benne előbb-utóbb
és talán ez az egyik ez az egyik
gyengeségem és azt gondolom hogy ebbe
tudom sőt tudom most már tudatosan tudom
hogy ebbe kell fejlődjek sokat a amúgy
ide hozzátenném ez ez nekem is az egyik
terület ahol a ahol ami a gyengeségem én
is egy konfliktus kerülő személy vagyok
és azt vettem észre hogy hajlamosabb
vagyok a kétszínűségre üüm hogy hogy
hagyom hogy elfertőződjenek a dolgok nem
mondom meg a véleményem mosolygok amikor
nem kéne mosolyogni
és és abszolút erről van szó hogy meg
kellett tanuljam hogy hogyan vállaljam
fel a konfliktust
van-e valami történet így az életedben
ami így ki csillan így az elmúlt pár
évből ami ami amikor érezted hogy nagyon
nehéz volt de azáltal hogy megharcoltad
azáltal tényleg fejlődtél
egyet nem tudom hogy van-e így most egy
történet ami így eszedbeüt ezzel
kapcsolatban hát most így hogyha kapásbó
kell mondani volt olyan volt olyan eset
hogy tárgyaltunk a az egyik
partnerünkkel vagy leendő potenciális
partnerünkkel és és mar mindenben meg
voltunk gyakorlatilag
egyezve sőt még a legelején volt úgyhogy
még két dolgokat hogy csináljuk meg
fejlesszünk még ezt azt bele és
ezt teljesítettük meg fontosnak
tartottuk hogy behozzuk és
talán egy-két hét van felhívott hogy
akkor
vagy vagy kapok egy ilyen nagyon
nevetséges százalékot vagy akkor nem nem
csatlakozom és
akkor gondolkoztam hogy oké akkor egyet
bólintok mindegy vagy megadjuk hogy
legyen tehát hogy legyen
hozzuk be és legyen egy húzónév vagy
vagy akkor beleállun a és azt mondom
hogy akkor ezt nem tudod amikor úgy
gondolod hogy hogy tényleg tiszteségesen
becs attól független hogy kezdők vagyunk
még ezen a területen de van ennek egy
egy egy egy tisztességes ára hogyha ezt
majd meg
tudod adni akkor akkor nyilván tgyaltunk
és és akkor ez ez történt hogy a hogy a
második opcióval mentünk és azt mondtam
hogy nincs üzletopció akkor nincs
üzletopció tehát ha nem winwin ugye
akkor nincs üzlet és nem volt üz lett és
jó döntés volt jó döntés volt mert
azt gondolom hogy nem nem lett volna
fertebbiekkel vagy más partnereinkkel
szembe és akik tényleg azt mondták hogy
oké jövünk nézzük meg csináljuk meg
együtt hogy hogy egy ilyen üzletbe
belemenjünk ühüm most hányan vagytok a
cégnél hát most a backofice egy olyan
10-12 személy az az j mondom 1012 mert
folyamatosan változik most négyen vagy
hár vagy négyen szülésé vannak meg ők
nyilván őket nem számmoltam mind aktív
ühüm dolgozók de hogy egyébként ezt is
ezt is szeretjük azért támogatni
bármilyen fájdalmas is de
de tényleg sok olyan hegy alkalmazottunk
volt aki aki legtöbben elmentek szülésé
de ez teljesen normális az a az élet
velejárója és attól független tehát
legtöbb helyen azt látom hogy harag vagy
valamilyen feszültség keletkezik amiatt
mer mert
ő most gyereket válló de szerintem ez az
nem normális hozzáállás az a normális
hozzáállás hogy egy 20-30 éves
nő akkor akkor neki neki ez egy ha ő úgy
érzi akkor ez egy ez egy feladat az egy
felelőssége és a cég is kell támogassa
abba hogy akkor oké jön időben szól az
megfelelő utánpótlást biztosítsuk és
mikor tényleg ott van akkor szívesen
vágjuk vissza
igen hát ez ez abszolút érvényes a érzem
én is a piacon hogy szinte büntetve
vannak a a fiatal hölgyek tehát félnek
bevallani hogy szeretnének gyereket
vállalni mert lehet hogy akkor nem
alkalmazzák vagy nem kapnak
fizetésemelést és ez ez nagyon sokat
foglalkozhat ez a téma és a maradék pár
percünkben most nem akarok nagyon mélyen
belemenni de úgy azért a hallgatók
kedvéére elmondom hogy ha ennyire
büntetjük a gyermekvállalást akkor ne
csodálkozzunk hogy a a szaporulati
indexe európának ilyen alacsony tehát
hogy ahhoz hogy fennmaradjon a népesség
2,1 gyermekkel szülessen két
szülő után na most most ez az index
magyarországon talán 1,6 körül van
valami ilyesmi valami ilyesmi ami egy
egész jó számnak számít tehát most
hallottam hogy máltán 1,2 egyszerűen és
és görögországba omlik össze a az európa
népessége úgyhogy persze nehezen kötjük
össze a szaporulati indexet és ezt a
fajta haragot amit te említettél de
valójában össze tehát egyé egyértelműen
csak annyi hogy pár év eltolódás van a
kettő között ha ma büntetem a
munkatársamat amiatt mert mert gyermeket
vállal akkor ne csodálkozzak hogy 10 év
múlva sokkal kevesebb gyermek fog
születni mert amit jutalmazunk az
növekszik és amit büntetünnk az az az
viszont csökken abszolút van relevancia
egyébként én is azt látom és taln a
vállalkozoktl a legnagyobb tehát
szerintem a legnagyobb akodal az a
félelem hogy akkor most most elmegy és
hogy fogjuk pótolni vagy
kényelmetlen kényelmetlen meg meg ki
kell képezni új embert rá de de pont ez
hogyha egy picit nem fáj akkor nincs
fejlődés és nem is tudom már ki mondta
de de ez a nagy igazság hogyha hogyha
benne vagy két-három évig a
vállalkozásodban is úgy kényelmes meg
minden akkor akkor az nem jó hogyha
fejlőd fejlődést vársz akkor akkor
valami csak kell fájjon akkor valami
történik akkor kezdesz tergeszkedni jön
egy-két pofon az azér faj vagy kezdesz
növekedni vagy kimész egy szoftverrel a
piacra elbukik az is faj de ez is egy
egy fejlődés eg így van így van ez egy
zálog fejlődésednek s annak hogy hogy
hosszút távon tudod működtetni azt a
céget akoka szóval visszatérve az
eredeti kérdésre azért kérdeztem ezt meg
hogy van tizenpár ember a backoffice-b
és még hány ember aki a futárként
dolgozik hát körülbelül van egy ez
nagyon változó de egy olyan 80 80 futá
szaladgál a
elképesztőutak ezt akartam megkérdezni
hogy azért ez már nem kis teher tehát
hogyha most csak az anyagi vonzatát
nézzük hogy mekkora lehet az a minimális
forgalom ami ami zéróba tartja ezt a
céget hogy alszol nyugodtan
éjszaka sokkal nehezebb volt akkor
amikor még nyilván sokkal nehezebb volt
amikor még ilyen 2022 április előtt
amikor nagyon ilyen nulla mínusz plusz
körül konvergádunk
valahogy valahogy van egy ilyen vannak
azért nehezebb nehezebb napok vagy
nehezebb éjszakák de valahogy van egy
ilyen béke hogy hogy igyekszünk tényleg
a legjobb tudásunk szerint csinálni én
is igyekszem a legjobb tudásom szerint
csinálni a feladataimat építeni a céget
és talán talán ez adja meg azt a békét
hogy hogy hogy azért mégis mégse
történhet olyan olyan nagy dolog hogy
nyilván lehet ilyen nagyon v viszmajor
helyzet de nem történet olyan nagy dolog
ami ami azt eredményezi hogy itt
hirtelen összeomlik minden persze megvan
vannak olyan külső történetek amik
bármikor előfogdulat nagy isten de az
hogyha a piacot nézzük és a és ennek a
tendenciát akkor
akkor van egy fajta egészséges önbizalom
ühüm és talán ez az egészséges önbizalom
adja azt hogy mert én egy alapvetően egy
nagyon-nagyon hiányzott belőlem az
önbizalom nagyon sokáig ühüm és még most
is talán ez is a másik gyengeségem hogy
nincs meg az a nincs meg a sokszok a
kellő kellően bizalmam magamban de de
ezzel kapcsolatban ú gondolom hogy hogy
hogy megvan és meg is kell legyen mert
enélkül azért tényleg nehéz nehéz
éjszakák lennének hogy mert azért
tényleg van egy eléggé eléggé nagy
nagy
költsége tehát van egy nagy havi
költsége egy operatív költsége ennek a
annak a működtetésének és van egy
felelősség is
de de azt azt gondolom hogy ez a ez a
típusú bizalom a cégbe a piacba az
emberekbe sokba
adja azt hogy hogy ezt így nyugodtan
lehet csinálni talán tehát nem is kevés
operatív költséglet így most érzés
alapjá azt mondanám hogy olyan 80000
euró 100000 euró körül lehet a
havi szükségletetek és ez ez nem kevés
most nem tudom hogy belőttem-e jól de de
de a nagyságrendje szerintem kábé
nagágrendje igen hát olyan szempontból
változó hogy ugye a futárok esetében
nagyon sokan vannak akik ilyen néhány
órában vannak
munka mellett meg meg
kis műzakb igen egy picvel kevesebb de
attól még úgy gondolom hogy ez nem
kevésén nem vagyunk egy nagy cég tehát
egy ilyen kis kis vállalk kis vállalat
vagyunk de attól független a mi
léptékünkben ez tényleg nem kevéssolút
és hogyha azt nézzük hogy mondjuk
2019-ben milyen forgalmat bonyolítottunk
és gyakorlatilag ezt meg tíszereztük
négy év alatt elképesztő akkor akkor úgy
kicsit úgy nem mondom hogy a pillangok
kezdenek így a az emberek gyomrába így
felébredni de de azért van van egy
típusú felelősség hát ha ilyet mondhatok
akkor én nagyon büszke vagyok arra hogy
ismerlek téged és hogy elindultatok ezen
a pályán és egy egy egy igazi égkő vagy
akit lehet figyelni és lehet nézni így a
biznis világba egy kicsit még mesélj
arról hogy ekkora teher mellett hogy
tudod a családi egyensúlyt megtartani
tehát a munkacsalád viszony az az hogy
alakul nálatok van két gyer hány évesek
a gyermekeid négy éves a kislányom és
másfél éves a fiam hogy tudsz figyelni
rájuk most most már azért
így hogy tudatosan csinálom azt gondolom
hogy egyre jobban
itt főleg az elején volt nehéz amikor
amikor még elindultunk és ott tényleg
sokkal többet dolgoztam mint most nem
mond akkor még nem voltak megszületve
akkor ha né éves nem hát igen igen 2020
áprilisáan született ajna és
akkor még nehéz volt tehát az eljén ott
tényleg több energiát több időt kellett
belerakni főleg a főleg hogy a futár
sokszor én voltam meg az adminisztrációs
meg az értékesítő tehát hogy
gyakorlatilag sok szerepet be kellett
tölteni de a feleségem támogatott és
pont az volt amikor így a céget
elindítottuk hogy leültünk é és
megbeszéltük hogy akkor cég vagy inkább
egy stabil munkahely ühüm és egyértelmű
volt a választás hogy akkor ezt így mára
billen a a
mérlegnyelve és
talán pont ez a 2022-től amunor hogy
kicsit megnyugodtak a kedéek meg sokkal
azér nyugodtságot is adott meg több
bizalmat is em bizalmat is adott az hogy
most már most már nem azt kell nézni
hogy vajon jövő hónaprra
y hogy sikerül-e vagy hogy tudjuk
tologatni vagy mit tudunk tologatni meg
hogy fizessük ki
főleg annak tudata aban hogy hogy mi az
az első legfontosabb dolog az hogy az
emberek eket kifizessük időbe és és
korrekten
úgyhogy akkor kezdett kicsit úgy kezdett
ez a háborgótenger megnyugodni és akkor
akkortól már tudatosabban tudtam
figyelni arra hogy hogy azért van egy
családom addig is azért én alapból egy
családközpontú családból nevet
nevelkedtem és ezt is hozom magammal
úgyh hogy ez fontos számomraüm tehát
tényleg első a család és
az azóta azóta azért egyre tudatosabban
és tudatosabban
csinálom ami még nagyon nehéz hogy
megfogjam a telefonomat és félretegyem
valahova és azt mondjam hogy akkor
tényleg most a gyerekeimmel játszuk vagy
mer rájuk koncentrálok de mondjuk az
utóbbi néhány hónapban erre igyekeztem
minél jobban figyelni és hálistennek
ennek azért a gyümölcsei megvannak mert
érzem hogy hogy nem kell ott legyen
egyébként oké hogy lehet hogy keresnek
vagy valaki valamivel kapcsolatba de nem
kell akkor meg válaszoljam ha akkor meg
kell akkor meg hívnak meg jelez az órám
vagy valami van
de nem szükséges nyilván ez is egy fajta
azt gondolom hogy ez egy ez most az
társadalom
99%-ának egy fajta függősége
ez nekem is kihívás amúgy tehát hogy
hogy hogyan figyeljek a gyermekeimre
viszont azt tapasztalom hogy ha sikerül
figyelni egy 15-20 percet valahogy úgy
beleszeretek a pillanatba és már egyre
könnyebb tehát hogy utána már egy-két
óra úra játék után már igen akkor már
nem is jön hogy már núj a telefonon után
igen én is ezt érzem egyébként pontosan
hogy hogy
sokkal nagy energiabfektetés nagy
kihívást jelent az hogy hogy ezt meglépt
hogy tényleg csak csak velük foglalkoz a
családdal foglalkoz de de sokat jelent
tehát ennek a gyümölcse sok szogosa akár
annak az időnek amit mondjuk elvesztesz
hagy később válaszolsz vagy vagy
teljesen mindegy hogy mi történik a a
egyébként a hogyha valami sürgesség van
nyilván akkor akkor más történet de
ritka hálistennek erre már a megfelelő
emberek meg tudják oldani a a sürgessebb
dolgokat is úgyhogy igyekszem és hogyha
úgy van akkor igyekszünk néha néha egy
kávitt beiktatni a feleségemmel meg
közösen töltött időt bár nem könnyű mert
most ő most doktorizik mellette ilen ped
modult végez meg mellette m gyereknál is
van szóval összességében egy elég húzós
időszak de azért igyekszük ezt
igyekszünk ezt is úgy kezelni hogy hogy
ne menjen semmi családi családra vasár
egyértelmű még lenne vagy 10 kérdésem de
azt hiszem hogy itt ez egy jó pont hogy
lezárjuk ezt a beszélgetést talán
egy-két év múlva vagy pár hónap múlva is
talán amikor lássuk hogy vásárhelyen
hogy alakul a a a stratégiátok üljünk le
és beszélgessünk lehet hogy akkor majd
felteszem ezeket a kérdések mindenesetre
nagyon hálás vagyok hogy megismertelek
és nagyon hálás vagyok hogy eljöttél ide
székelyudvarhelyre és egy kicsit
beszélgethettünk ezekről a kérdésekről
lenne-e még valami ami amit így utólag
még esetleg elszeretnél mondani vagy nem
kérdeztem rá még talán egy két percet
szánhatunk
rá
hú nem tudom azt gondolom hogy sok
mindenről beszéltünk és sok mindent
körbejártunk nyilván ott
a kérdésett közöt még voltak vagy a
a amikor kitalltottam azt az őlapot
akkor voltak még témák de azt gondolom
hogy hogy kell kell az idő hogy minden
minden szépen körbeá most hrtalán nem
fogalmazódik meg semmi bennem de nagyon
szépen köszönöm a a meghívás ezt a
beszélgetés tényleg felüdülés volt
elrepült az idő köszönöm szépen
köszönöm ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor
iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel
tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávé közöss a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre